good morning everyone my name is James
and it is my pleasure to introduce our
next speaker I believe this is souls
third PI data appearance so I'd like to
give a round of applause for South Diaz
gira thanks Jett hehe tried we worked on
the car here to get him to say my name
correctly but you know you can't do that
okay cool so yeah my name is Sal de
Guerra that's good enough and we're here
to talk about speed without drag which
as you will come to find it's a lie I'm
electronics engineer who somehow majored
in CS and somehow I ended up building
web applications but most of what I did
for the past three years has been
building Python back-end systems that
are heavily numerical for other Tyson
and so you know it's not the first time
I I need to just beat my Python last
year I give a couple talks James were
saying on numba which we will talk about
shortly after talks there was always a
question of okay this is great it it
just sounds like it might work what else
is there what else can I use and I just
limited to this so i decided to you know
take a step back and try to get a little
more comprehensive about the options you
have to to speed up your python when any
of you do
so with that being said let's just start
and I'd like to start the talk is about
how you what what tools like what
libraries and tools you're you know are
available to you too so you can escape
the safety of Python but the first part
of the talk is going to be about trying
you not to trying to get you not to do
that and so whenever you're whenever you
bump into the hole oh my my coach stirs
load is this batch process i was doing
is taking too long I would advise to
think first thing you know try not to
jump again and try to put it on a GPU
just for kicks right so I think that's
important that's something that you need
to check yourself first before you you
start going some going down some rabbit
hole so what if instead of you know
using number or using something else
you've thought it through and refactor
code that might not be a performant
because you wrote it in a in a small
period of time what if you threw money
at the problem maybe it's easier for you
to just you know throw throw it on I'm
easy to paralyze it and its really
simple bashing and you know call it
quits of course about the cost of
opportunity because you know you might
need to do something better with your
time then deal with multi-processing
openmp whatever it is you you need to do
to actually speed up your code or you
know you can just blame it on to jail
van rossum and switch to Java so as I
was saying first I I I would advise to
you rule out other problems and this is
broken wait a minute yeah okay
okay fine so what if you fix io problems
you have I bottlenecks serializing
something else that isn't really
computation being slow because if your
competition is not being slow to begin
with the things we're going to see here
today won't really help you if you have
a DB axis that's dragging you down you
can't apply all the numpy you you want
it's start going to help again right
you're coding in ways that make sense
don't compile a red x over and over
don't don't do stupid things that you
might overlook don't compute anything
you will discard of course the tools are
used make sure you know like randoms you
might not need as many random stuff as
you as you think you need and many other
things that we want you to talk about
today but I'm sure you you all know a
bit about doors are still linked to oh
by the way let's go back here I uploaded
this ipython notebook to that URL in
case you want to access head here now or
later including the link that we just
bumped into now which is a link to
attack by a man named David shatter and
let's see and he talks about speeding
python up up to think of what's a
hundred and fourteen thousand times
completely different approach to what
we're going to discuss today so it's
mostly you know really low level heads
on stuff completely if our approach but
worth taking a look into worth keeping
in mind as well
you know as far as C Python goes capture
the low-hanging fruit huge
multiprocessing whenever you can realize
that for the most part you're only using
one core so if you can add that and the
overhead doesn't kill you you will
automatically get speed gains and those
low my my bottleneck you at the end of
it but that's fine do things like
checking that you're not repeatedly
creating temporary storage that you can
use and you have to discard it means is
not performant now use obscure quote
unquote language features like slots
that will help you bring your for
examples lots will help your objects be
smaller than us faster use
comprehensions faster banned these
generators I'm sure you most of you by
now have heard James talk on toxin
generators they are really helpful when
you bumped into speed problems but you
know especially if you are listening to
him don't use this code but that's not
the point of targets the point of talk
is to actually go over libraries and
tools that will help you circumvent the
safety of Python because when you what
we have to understand is that whenever
we use these things for the most part
the tools are trying to help us not
shoot ourselves in the foot but chance
you're you're basically giving up a lot
of the nice things that Python does for
you once you start going down this path
so spit with its speed with no drag
without drag let's just claim that it's
speed with limited drag we're going to
go over plenty of tools
such as exhausting poop Ivan that we
already did side by numpy number perky
nomics / via new pipe I numpy Python
blaze by Tyson scene finally python who
Mary will talk later about the way we're
going to do this not sure if it's a good
idea or not but it's too late to to
recalculate is by using a driving
example I wrote a really simple function
that calculates the area of a polygon
based on its coordinates this is a
really simple Dara sorry this is a
really simple piece of code that can get
really slow as you come up with complex
polygons and so we're going to see how
the different libraries and tools deal
with it as a disclaimer James was saying
yesterday how measuring libraries and
tools under speed with a limited example
and in a limited way because some tools
for example we're going to be using Thea
new on this without without GPU support
it's really unfair for for us to to
compare to noon in that way but this is
more a general walkthrough of what the
options are then anything else so let's
let's start with your normal case which
would be using C Python period can we
see that I guess so what we have here is
a generator that will create coordinates
to a polygon that looks basically like a
bunch of stairs and we're going to be
generating polygons that are
I think to 200,000 steps which comes to
about a around 1 million coordinates so
that's just that and this is actually
the function that you would write in C
Python I you know the first attempt the
the way you I get to the area is
basically adding up the the result of
multiplying X sub zero x/x x x y sub I
plus 1 minus y sub I times X sub I plus
1 i'm dividing that by by 2 so that
works and if we were if we run that with
the wooded 200,000 step polygon which is
again around a million coordinates we
get around half a second which is fine
obviously this for the sake of and talk
we could get it to be really really
slowly but one or two so let's see what
what other what the libraries and tools
were we're about to discover do with it
so small note on sci-fi sci-fi is not a
sample is not something that we would
use for this because the calculation is
really simple but depending on what you
do sci fi as you all know it's a library
that has type idea lab the library not
the not this tag or the project as a
whole is the library that has lots of
helpers so depending on what you're
doing you might benefit from looking
into what type I has to offer there so
what we are going to use from from
decide by stag dough is numpy as as you
all know it's the n dimensional array
library from side by and just by loading
our coordinates in in a numpy ray we
will get some benefits and yes as you
know it's it's a prop it's a it's a
product that's been around for a while
and the way it helps us escape pythons
safety is by by going down to see em for
trend when it needs to so to use numpy
we just you know we create a dia ray and
then we write the the functions in I
don't know if people can see this but I
Python nut book won't really use them in
any way what we're doing here is
basically indexing the DRA and selecting
the columns and then doing vector that
just set the same exact calculation only
vectorized and in doing that we go from
half a one-fourth of a second to too
close to nine milliseconds so that's
something you know releasing the speeds
are the speedup is it's obvious some
other things we can use our number while
using numpy as well number is a
just-in-time compiler of Python that
uses llvm as a back-end to speed up your
Python what that means is number will
read your your Python it will build a
syntax tree and translate that to the
intermediate representation of llvm
which is a modern c compiler and then
we'll then number will use the llvm
output to to run
your code so basically you won't be
running Python anymore you will be
running you will be running generated
machine code from from llvm instead as I
said just happens in judgment
just-in-time compilation so it's pretty
fast some other things to mention it has
experimental CUDA support you can
compile your your methods or in your
classes through pie CC so you can have
actually them you can do away with the
with the jet and then have it statically
compiled and 4 volt that need GPU or
multi-core continuum has a paid service
called number pro part of accelerate I
think and there's a there's a link there
to the numba talk I gave last year in
case you're not entirely bored with me
now you can continue learn about number
there for now we're just going to see
the most immediate example using numba
which is basically creating a new
function that's decorated with the jet
or a legit method of number and as soon
as we run that method number well get
the code analyze it and basically switch
the results live by doing that you know
we go from eight point five milliseconds
to 28 so it's not a big speed up
obviously numpy is really optimized to
begin with so it's it's hard to it's
hard to make it better just by by
analyzing it although
what you do you will be able to get
number two to speed up not by in some
fashion unrelated to the shoelace
example which is the way the name of the
of the calculation i wanted to mention a
really nifty feature of numba for those
of you who deal with you funks usually
you can create customs custom you funks
and have them vectorized you can also do
this with with numpy but the numpy
result is not as as great and we're
missing a damn it there okay so here
we're basically doing us a square on an
array if we do it with with numpy
vectorized it takes 200 milliseconds if
we use the square in numpy and then at
one and it takes way way less and if we
use the number of vector Iser it's
slightly faster so that's something to
consider especially because you know in
this case given that an example is quite
simple numpy had a square method that's
obviously a real performance but
depending on what you're doing and what
you're you funk to us you might not be
able to to do that and you might have to
use this or something else one other
library somewhat related to to number is
parakeet para kid was originally
basically the same sort of llvm
mechanism but somehow along the way
turned into specialized
imitations of many functions manual
instead of so instead of
programmatically trying to infer what
your codes doing our kid implemented
many many functions natively and finally
they change their their back-end from
llvm to to see and they are also using
OpenMP by default also experimental
support for CUDA as well same thing as
number really simple application
mechanism once you have your coding
place you decorate it with the JIT
method did you just run it and we can
see how we went from well this is this
particular run it's slightly weird cuz
no yeah I guess it makes sense so what
happens here is we decorated both the
dalvahni LSC python code which
unfortunately gets slower which probably
means you know that Park it can't really
tell what's going on so it just wastes
time and then when we use an umpire
version that you can actually tell and
it goes down from 8.5 to 21 something
milliseconds which is crazy and I
believe it's the best result of all
these tests one thing that you really
need to take into account for both
number and park it is that there's a lot
of work building de da st in a way that
makes sense and in a way that they can
actually do something with it so
depending on what your code does
depending on what things what lexical
piping things you use
they might not even be able to to speed
it up so in this case by just feeding
the normal vanilla C Python we don't get
anywhere it's the same I don't know if I
if I have it but it's the same result
for for a number as well it's problem is
that you know it's you would probably
have to annotate types or actually no I
tried annotating types in it didn't work
either so I don't know what you would
have to do but you would have to hit
that at both number are key to to be
able to speed up that that one one other
thing we can do and this is something I
really excited about is nomex / this is
a PI data project led by my fellow
countrymen francesco dead and what what
it does is it evaluates your vector
expressions and feeds them to the
processor in an ordered orderly fashion
so that the cast is maximized and they
also avoid creating intermediate values
so think of it as the something similar
as the typical string concatenation
example they have support for OpenMP and
for the vector math and kernels if you
need to do work with tres cendant
expressions it's a evaluated code is not
that the devaluated expressions are not
bad you know why it's not a huge set but
it's really useful and you will usually
see speedups about from about 5 to 10 x
what we do is as you can see we have to
index the gra preemptively because we
can't do it and evaluate expression and
then we just write some sort of
normal expression Clinton to some and
you know numpy was 8.5 dis this is to
2.5 which is which is pretty good what
else Fionna Fionna is probably the
oldest library here other than type I
it's a really complex library that does
many things and it's probably the one
that's represented the worst year so
what they do is they define the the
expressions the same way nomex will do
only in a more language semantically
semantic way but the real deal here is
and what we won't get to see is that
they have a seamless GPU support cuda
and lots of optimizations for really
obscure things it's tricky to install
because it's a lot of moving parts
anaconda will help you with that if you
if you need help for this example you
can see how we can create vectors with
the with the tensor and just to find the
expression once you do that you can run
the the function that results in some in
the same way and you know given that
it's not it's Forte really the result is
one order of magnitude slightly less
than an order of magnitude faster than
vanilla C Python but not as good as
numpy or nomex what else pi PI as you
know by-by is an implementation of jaded
implementation of Python that's
completely complete standalone separated
from C Python
and you know it's pretty much her it
mostly works and numpy pot numpy has a
car cinder cold called num pie pie that
works so if we were to run this this
same code this is outside the ipython
notebook but if we were to run this code
the same code we've been running we've
got did we would get this result which
is really really good that is if I'm not
mistaking less than a millisecond so I
guess para cave wasn't the best after
all but and that's the Python version
which is awesome because you know we
didn't really do and if we wouldn't have
to do any work we wanted to use numpy
pie you can go to that URL to check the
support for it we wanted to use that
what we will find is that it's you know
slightly less it's not as fast as a spy
pious regular pie by it so I guess
they'll have to keep working on that but
it's a only know both pie pie and um pai
pai our valid options if if that's what
you what you think its operational best
for you and yeah this is the the same
exact code run on NYE pathing that book
so to miss the slide so basically we
have the abnormal code that takes in
this case there's an order of magnitude
difference here because I had to yeah so
I had to downgrade the two hundred
thousand steps to just two thousand so
the numbers might be skewed what that
means is that pipe I still slower than
both see pipe both the Python in
endon pie and numpy pious lower didn't
um pai pai it by by a little by little
in the case of pi pi by l by a lot in
the case of of numpy by there was a
slight comparing them but somehow it got
misplaced right other than that we've
got Jason Jason as the Python
implementation on the JVM it's pretty
easy to install and and it was pretty
seamless to actually get it to work the
code run more or less in the same time
so it didn't really speed up that much
so yeah that's a that's a slight I was
talking about we can see how numpy and
see pythons really fast pi PI itself is
really fast numpy pious get into her and
Jotham just works as as well or so or as
bad as C Python does new things to just
keep track of but not really use by some
pie sting is a new implementation of
python that dropbox is working on it's
heavily based on llvm you could say
somewhat somewhat something like number
or parakeet but in and ending the entire
language scope note raising conservative
garbage collection calls being made and
they're doing the one thing that I'm
eager to to read more about which is
they're basically coming up with both
machine codes with type prediction and
as a fallback and or ransom between them
two depending on
under result life so that's that's
pretty interesting unfortunately it's
really really agreeing it's really
really knew that it doesn't even work on
the OS X so we'll we'll see where it
goes blaze I don't know if Travis spoke
about blaze in this conference but
blazes the new num pie or will be
someday it's a cloud big data a numpy
yes please crench and it will help you
do whatever all the things that no pie
helps you do only with support for large
distributed and heterogeneous data sets
lots of adapters to to get that to work
seamlessly um and that's the URL and you
know when all else fails you can use C
extensions it siphons to type since eff
I a dud pointy or your drag is more than
apparent so you're on your own I wanted
to talk about Python for a second
pythons the next talk Mary will be
talking about what python is and what it
does but it's basically a transpiler
that takes your Python into c plus into
modern c plus players throw annotations
like like we saw with numba and parkade
it it's got some interesting support and
it's pretty exciting so I'm really
looking forward to to hearing him and
that's basically how it looks which is
exactly the same the same weight number
and park you look so to recap there
ain't no such thing as a free speed up
so keep that in mind thank first try to
avoid going down this road because it's
it's easy but it's not that easy and
just you know choose whatever
it's best for for the job thanks boiler
so I have a piece of code that it's
generated into Python its serial code
that just a bunch of ifs some
computations and assignments nothing
very complex from all of those tools
which one should I use so the code is
really simple it it's automatically
generated by a system oh it's
automatically generated yeah it's Python
code the generated out of something else
yeah and what's that what's that kind of
data that the code its computations
basically it's monte carlo simulation
compiled into a python file can it be
vectorized and in any way ah not really
it's it's it's spaghetti code really
it's just this value of this parameter
gets this expression and then several if
that's it and the topics itself many
many times it's really spaghetti it's
not nothing very complete nothing very
intelligent yeah that's that's
interesting so if it's if it's not
really if it's mostly scholars it's
interesting because most of these toes
will help you speed up things that are
you know arrays basically so I wonder
what the performance gains would be with
just scholars i would say tribe pi PI
first cuz you know it's a entire
language optimization it fails on it
failed in the past and some things
didn't pass dang then it might not be
that simple right I think it was some
library or something because I do use
math libraries if I total colt was a
long time ago but in that case I'd say
try with Ian isolate especially with
with really excluding excluding pi PI
and Jason and you know python whatever
it comes out and and whatever when
you're used when you're just using
libraries you should try to isolate the
part of the of your code that's being
slow and you should try to speed that up
is that part I would do that I will I
would easily the slow part and try out
with the end of it probably but if
you're if you're basically being blocked
on results coming from third-party
libraries that might not be as simple
you might not be able to leverage these
things so you tell me that dude is no
easy way this is what you're trying if
you're if you depend on on third-party
libraries that are not that simple then
they know if your if your code is just
you know a bunch of even else's in
normal types I would say you know use
pipe i use try theatre but really like
if it's that simple just writing and see
ok thank you
three two one Thanks oh sorry for the
the jai phone numbers did that include
the time to start up the JVM was it a
cold start no that's uh I was using the
Python timer so I would assume that it
didn't include that which yeah that's a
good point right thank you